we had two thousand seven hundred
fifty-five people on the
forbes world's billionaires list this
year which is a record number
we have 493 new billionaires um in the
past 12 months
where we had only 178 newcomers last
year amid the pandemics
this is a huge jump i mean just the
newcomers this year from
china which is 205 is more than
the newcomers from the entire world last
year the previous
record was in 2015 where we had 290
newcomers
so huge increase of the 493
we were looking at how these people
ended up on the list why are they new
and the majority of them was they
already had
companies that they'd founded or owned
part of and the stock just went up
we had ipos and then there was a smaller
number
who um landed on the list because of um
investing in cryptocurrency
bitcoin hit you know record highs this
year one of the richest newcomers
in europe is guillaume poussais of a
company called checkout.com
that helps with online payments and we
also had in the united states
max levchin from a firm a fintech
company
newcomer so we saw a few of those also
the two founders of klarna which is a
swedish company also payments company
one of the the youngest self-made woman
on the list is
whitney wolf heard of the dating app
bumble bumble went public
from earlier this year and she owns a
big stake in the company and she's worth
1.3 billion
the youngest self-made new youngest
self-made billionaire
um is a billionaire who got who uh
dropped out of stanford his name is
austin russell he's 26
and he started a a company that makes
um these automotive sensors it's called
luminar technologies
for 3d vision for for self-driving cars
and
that went public in a spac merger and
he's worth 2.6 billion dollars china has
626 billionaires this year and that's
not including hong kong macau which we
uh count separately so if you include
both territories
uh it's 698. so it's just behind the us
which has 724
and that's that's a big increase because
last year's china only had 388 people
uh in the shanghai market in the
stringent market um there's a record
amount of money raised on the hong kong
stock exchange
in 2020. we have a couple new
billionaires
um that are from vaping
so one is kate wayne who is one of the
world's youngest self-made female
billionaires
39 and she has a company called rlx
technology that produces e-cigarettes
and the other is chain gp
who also runs a vaping company that's
actually the biggest
manufacturer of vaping devices in the
world
there's steven yang who founded anchor
which
it sells iphone battery packs
and wall chargers and cables and the
other
is lee shan who i founded two u.s
listed companies one being electric
vehicle
maker lee alto that just went public on
the nasdaq in 2020.
and we have about 40 or more
billionaires who joined the list because
of
products they were producing during
cobit most of these are healthcare
billionaires
so um we have the ceo of moderna
stephen barnsell who you know obviously
modernist stock has shot up because of
its vaccines we also have the co-founder
of biohome tech which partnered with
pfizer for pfizer's adobe vaccine
and we have an italian newcomer
named sergio stevenado which people may
not recognize his name
but he owns a company that
produces glass files that kobe 19
vaccines are actually stored in when you
work on the list and
and you see how the stock market was
doing the past year we did we were
always expecting
a high number of billionaires this year
but it always does surprise you when you
sit down and see how many
there really were and and just i think
the one thing that was really surprising
was just the breadth of where everyone
comes from you know
there are people who made money from
biotech and
healthcare which we expected but it's
also you know things like crypto because
um bitcoins and other cryptocurrencies
have gone up so much you know we have
uh the winco boss twins um who invested
in bitcoin 2012
at 12 per coin and now it's 58 000
per coin and then we have you know stack
ipos where
uh you have both stack sponsors who
created these
blank check companies becoming
billionaires and then you have tech
company
founders who became billionaires because
they merged their
um company with specs and you know we're
seeing
fintech um taking off with a lot of
people doing at-home trades
um and uh you know we're seeing
obviously a lot of tech company all
taking off electric vehicle companies
taking off
and so really across the board
it's just kind of a record-breaking year